[Music]
floyd mayweather is set to make an
estimated 100 million dollars from his
fight with logan paul
cementing his position as one of the
highest paid athletes in history
i can guarantee you this june 6 you will
get knocked out
logan paul on the other hand is set to
make 20 million dollars a fifth of what
mayweather gets but still
i like the king of cats bro you're the
king of cat
ain't a boxer anymore champ you're right
you're right you're tired
100 mil 20 mil for just 18 minutes in
the ring i don't know about you
but that kind of money in exchange for
18 minutes in the ring was some possible
brain damage
i don't know i would probably take that
deal floyd and logan aren't alone though
george foreman sits as the second
richest boxer in history and an
estimated net worth of 300 million
dollars
from 76 wins and five losses followed by
manny pacquiao at number three with an
estimated 220 million as 62 wins seven
draws and two losses
oscar de la hoya at 200 million with 39
wins and six losses
and lennox lewis at 140 million with 41
wins two draws and one loss
the question is where does all this
money come from
this is the economics of one of the most
interesting sports businesses out there
boxing
[Music]
[Applause]
after watching this video you're
probably gonna want to keep up with all
the drama of the mayweather logan paul
fight
and of all the future fights and drama
to come so you're gonna have to switch
to twitter to see what they're trash
talking over there then switch to
instagram to do the same thing then
maybe tick-tock
it's a mess if only there was a place
where all the best content from all
these fragmented social media platforms
could be curated so you don't have to
constantly switch between apps
enter faves a brand new free app that's
sponsoring this video where you can find
the best youtube videos instagram posts
tweets tech talks and more all in one
place
on there you can share your favorite
content from any app and build a big
following around your tastes there's
already all kinds of badass people
posting their favorite content to face
including the heads of products at
tiktok robin hood and google venture
capitalist from sequoia a16z and
lightspeed best-selling authors like the
author of hooked
tech icons like marissa mayer and also
myself you can see what they're reading
watching and scrolling through so you
can consume content like the best which
i really like
and here's the coolest part since the
app is in its early phases you get to
have direct conversations with all these
badass leaders before everyone else
floods in
more than 20 thousand people yes you've
heard that right 20 000 people have
signed up for the apps waitlist but
lucky for you i brokered a deal with our
team and they're gonna let you guys have
early access
all you have to do to skip the waitlist
is click the link below in the video
description
the first five thousand you to sign up
will get to skip the line and get access
to face within just 24 hours
so don't wait pause the video click the
link below and reserve your spot now
at its most basic level you have a
boxing match the mayweather pal fight
and each fight has a prize money pool
that both fighters get a cut of no
matter who wins
this means as long as you step in the
ring and fight no matter if you lose get
knocked out or have a draw
you get a portion of the prize money
that's why pro boxing is also called
prize fighting
that prize money is also called the
purse so whenever you hear people
talking about a hundred million dollar
purse or a 500 million dollar purse all
that means is that's the amount of prize
money on the table
for a boxing match for the infamous
floyd mayweather versus manny pacquiao
fight back in 2015
that purse was reportedly half a billion
dollars
mayweather got 60 of that purse or 300
million dollars
and pacquiao walked away with 200
million dollars in the case of the
mayweather paul fight the purse is an
estimated 100 million dollars
but in this case mayweather gets not 60
of that purse
but 80 or 80 million dollars while logan
paul only gets to walk away with 20
million dollars
why the uneven split both of them are
stepping in the ring and risking their
lives
it's simple it's because the prize money
is made up of how many people buy the
pay-per-view show ticket sales and other
broadcasts
for example with the mayweather pacquiao
fight here's how the purse broke down
69 came from pay-per-view sales 17 from
tickets 8
and 3 from other broadcasts and 3 from
other revenue streams
[Music]
meaning that the fighter with the most
notoriety with the bigger fan base
with a greater influence is going to
contribute more to the price money
they're able to drive more sales
so therefore they're able to negotiate a
bigger cuts that's why mayweather was
able to get 60 on the pie with pacquiao
and why even with logan paul's giant
audience mayweather was able to secure a
whopping eighty percent of that purse
logan paul's only had two fights one
indiana loss and another in the draw
he's going into mayweather's turf
so mayweather has all the leverage on
top of the purse money
fighters also make money on the back end
with things like merge sales
sponsorships for the fight and more
that's why mayweather is projected to
bring home a hundred million dollars
from the logan paul fight
80 million comes from the purse and 20
million from his back in businesses like
the money team merch
because how much money boxers make
completely depends on the numbers they
pull from the fight that's why there's
so much trash talking in boxing i know
what he did to japan so guess what
you have to pay for what you did to
japan bro i know what you did to your
wife
are you making this about race cause
it's always
[Music]
are you nervous floyd this wind is
picking up
strong gusty wicket blow your little ass
over the first rumblings of a mayweather
pacquiao fight was way back in 2010
fans were puffed the fight of the
century is gonna happen this year and
yet it took a whole five years of trash
talking going back and forth
negotiating the prize when he split
before the fight actually happened in
2015.
why you gotta build up the hype build up
the tension and drama
because the more hype the more
pay-per-view sales the more ticket sales
and the bigger the purse
do the math when floyd came to the
post-press conference they gave him his
first check
of 120 million to floyd mayweather at 60
percent of 200 million
manny pacquiao got 80 million in his 40
of 200 million man he did good manny
walked away with a 100 plus million
in his pocket floyd walked away with
probably i think
a little over 300 million damn you a
half a million
a half a billion i mean almost 500
million dollars he walked away with
that's how the boxing game goes boxing
business 101
bud must start talking more trash
building his followers up selling out
the gate in the business of boxing
everything leading up to the fight is
theater both fighters have to do their
part to make the fight marketable
which usually consists of a lot of trash
talking and drama
come on one night gotcha
logan ain't gonna go very well for you
i would still have no faith that you
could beat up before day one
is this fight bad for boxing i think it
is
i don't like it but one thing we go one
thing we do do
we kick ourselves that's one thing i do
do yeah we do we kick ass that's one
thing that we do
do so trash talk your way to a giant
purse then walk home 100 million dollars
right
well not so fast because once you get
your giant payday
there's a lot of hands you have to feed
[Music]
as a football star in the nfl your life
is a lot easier
you work as an employee to the nfl the
richest sports league in the world and
as a w2 employee
you get fat paychecks every two weeks
you get benefits but as a boxer
you are literally your own business you
get paid as an independent contractor
per fight
no regular paychecks you aren't employed
by any of the boxing event promoters
if you don't fight you don't get paid
which means that you have to pay for
everything yourself
your manager your trader anyone else on
your team training expenses travel
expenses you have to file taxes
as a business you have to set up your
own merch your own sponsors basically
fighting is the easy part here's how it
works first you have your manager
managers are the middlemen between the
fight promoters and boxers
basically your manager's job is to guide
you through your career promoters offer
fights to you and your manager's job is
to say yes or no to which fights you
take on
ideally they should only choose fights
that you have a good chance of winning
if they match you up with a bunch of
people that are bigger than you stronger
than you and you lose
one is going to hurt your win-loss
record two is gonna discourage you and
hurt your confidence and three
you can only take so much head trauma
and brain damage
the life cycle of a fighter is short
there are only so many fights you can
take on every fight matters
so you have to make sure whoever you
have in your corner has your back
then there are the promoters these are
the guys that put together the fights
choose the opponents set up the venue
set up the tv deals
deal with all the personalities involved
and help hype the show
if you have five fights in one show your
job is to fill those slots with fights
fans will enjoy
basically it's an extremely high risk
high return job promoters want to put on
the best most entertaining fights
while managers want to put their
fighters in the safest most sure-fire
fights to get more wins under their
belts
so after a fight is over the promoter of
the fight pays you the fighter your cut
of the prize money
minus a 25 fee so already your prize
money is down 25
and then you pay your team your manager
takes a very big cut compared to other
sports
anywhere from 15 to 33 percent your
trainer takes another 10 to 15 percent
your cut man the guy who helps treat the
cuts on your face mid-fight so you don't
get disqualified for health concerns
he can get up to two percent add in the
daily weight for two sparring partners
food travel hotel and it wouldn't be out
of the ordinary for you to be left with
just thirty percent of your prize money
so if a fight gets you ten dollars you
end up keeping just three dollars
and then you have to pay taxes to uncle
sam for a brand new fighter starting
from the bottom with no amateur
experience
you'll probably get around a thousand
dollars per fight starting out
as you move up you'll maybe get to walk
away with 35 to 60k per fight
it's only when you get near the very top
that that 30 starts to really add up
and all this together the fact that as a
boxer you're really running a business
and all the expenses that come with that
is why people say ninety percent of
boxers die broke
you have to have kind of a fighter
mentality and a business mentality
because
ninety percent of boxes go broke which
is which is sad
percentage because even if you do end up
being one of the few that makes a lot of
money
being good at boxing and getting paid
for it is one thing keeping your wealth
preserving your wealth being a good
businessman is an entirely different
game
one requires taking risk getting in the
ring making a name for yourself
the other requires caution and a healthy
dose of paranoia
not blowing all your money on cars and
rollies right away
these young fighters want to buy ro they
see floyd mayweather with all the
watches
all the diamond chains all the cars they
have to invest their money
and that's what i try to teach them
teach them you know floyd maybe they're
able to buy a diamond chain car a house
every month from smart investments but
you know who are really good businessmen
floyd mayweather and logan paul
[Music]
fans want to see the most dangerous
exciting fights but mayweather realized
that it was in his best interest to take
on the least riskiest fights
why risk your life your healthier
reputation when you don't have to
and that's exactly what he did when the
idea of mayweather fighting pacquiao
first came up in 2010
pacquiao was in his prime so instead of
going up against pacquiao in his prime
floyd waited five years for him to age a
little get a little worn down
build up more and more hype to increase
that price money and then he fought
a more tamed version of pacquiao five
years later and walked away with a
hundred million dollars
and when conor mcgregor came along
mayweather realized that he doesn't even
have to fight boxers to make 100 million
dollars
a typical world title boxing match makes
him around 30 mil
a match like this 100 mil so why get in
the ring with someone who's trained
their whole life to box you for a measly
30 mil
when you can fight someone who isn't
even trained with more notoriety for a
hundred mil
you would take the ladder option every
single time as floyd calls it
it's a legalized bank robbery if it's
some easy like this
a legalized bank robbery i gotta do it
now he's making hundreds of millions of
dollars
fighting amateurs that's a great
business model which is where logan paul
comes in
[Music]
like we mentioned earlier most fighters
have to climb the ranks to maybe get to
a 20 million
payday but when logan lacks an
experience and wins he makes up for it
with an audience of over 20 million fans
and that's exactly what a great
profitable boxing match needs
not necessarily just skill but
personalities people care about
they need to know the characters
involved to be interested and they have
to believe that there's an interesting
obstacle in the way
and the great thing is if he loses
nothing happens it's what everyone
expects he walks away 20 million dollars
richer
but if he wins it will be the biggest
boxing upset of the century
what what happens if i win you know the
world axis
stands still time stops it's the genesis
it's the greatest
upset in the history of combat sports
what happens if i lose
nothing life goes on guys don't forget
to check out the new at faves
you can follow me on there at jaketran
and it's pretty cool you can check out
with the link below
what did you guys think about the
business of boxing i definitely didn't
think that there was this much to it
when i first started researching so it
was pretty cool to learn if you are new
here we make business video essays just
like this one every single week on the
most thought provoking and provocative
stuff
in the world of business from the
business of only fans to why chinese
billionaires keep disappearing to the
business of fine art so if you enjoyed
this one you're definitely going to
enjoy the other ones on the channel that
you can check out and you can subscribe
for more video essays just like this one
every single week
shout out to king lumos for following me
on instagram i'm following back one
person every single week at jaketrain.io
that's gonna wrap it up thank you so
much for watching you've been awesome
i've been jake stay dangerous out there
and i will see you guys in the next one
[Music]
you